chris you can have the first pick then
the best free agent signings of all time
what do you got okay i'm gonna try
it and i'm gonna i'm gonna avoid
quarterbacks a little here okay because
i mean we all we do is talk about
quarterback so i'm gonna try to be a
little different not the the disrespect
anybody remember one quarterback i take
in the third round but first off i mean
how do you not save reggie white i mean
reggie white is free agency to me he's
the poster child uh and you know of
course when he went into free agency he
was the best defensive player in the nfl
yeah might have been just leaving his
prime right there on the edge of it but
that was big news leaving that vaunted
philadelphia eagles team and whoa he's
going to join brett favre and the
packers watch out for them to me that'll
always be the the biggest free agent
signing i can remember
yeah i agree with you completely and and
that was the moment that free agency
became a thing for the nfl that yeah and
reggie white and this was a little
tweak in the settlement of the antitrust
lawsuit that was filed by the players
against the league after the 87 strike
imploded the union
went away and they filed that lawsuit
part of the settlement reggie white
could not be franchise tagged or he
would have been he would have been but
he was one of the named plaintiffs in
the name of the plaintiffs were not
allowed to be franchise tagged and
that's what allowed him to go on that
tour that put and there was phil getting
swallowed up by yeah we did reggie we
deserve a percentage of his salary there
he made in green bay i mean gosh phil
just you know got sacked by him all the
time and we we helped him out
i think didn't we have the trivia
question recently what he got on that
first contract it was four years 17
million dollars
something crazy like that
all right uh drew brees for me yeah the
free agent who
the
the
chargers in 2005 applied i believe the
franchise tag to keep him around his
original contract expired after 2004
they had drafted phillip rivers they
weren't ready to move on fully and
complete their rivers he became the free
agent with that shoulder injury that
happened in his final game with the
chargers 20 plus studs in his shoulder
the dolphins said we can't do it the
saints took the chance 15 years later he
retires as one of the great quarterbacks
of all time delivered as many super bowl
championships to new orleans as reggie
white did to green bay so uh drew brees
and you can make the argument that he's
even but when you consider full impact
on city the drew brees is even above
reggie white yeah i hear you there that
is it's definitely one of the greatest
free agent signings ever especially when
you take into account you're right the
circumstances of the city and then drew
brees's injury coming off of you know
the the shoulder surgery and all that uh
just remarkable you know what he did
from that point on it really is all
right my next one i'm staying on the
defensive side of the ball i'm going
prime time
prime time dion sanders yes dion sanders
might be you know you could say twice
you know whether it's going to the san
francisco 49ers in 1994 from the atlanta
falcons you sat there and you just went
oh man the 49ers are good are they as
good as the cowboys can they really beat
them and then they got dion and it gave
them a whole different feel and aura
about them to where you just went that
year you just went they're not gonna
they're winning the super bowl you know
between steve young and the way he got
going and dion doing pick sixes and all
of that and and then of course the next
year with dallas cowboys he goes there
and he wins the super bowl there so
deion sanders without a doubt to me is
is one of the greatest free agent
signings in the history of football yeah
absolutely and
and got a ring in 94 and a ring in 95
and a lot of money along the way peyton
manning yeah peyton manning 2012. they
lined up to get peyton manning he was
very careful he was judicious he
ultimately chose the broncos and right
out of the gates at a time when we
didn't know what he had left and if the
colts
had any idea how much he had left i
don't know would they have
would they have pressed pause on andrew
luck and kept peyton manning i i i'd
like to think that if you could get the
truth out of jim irsay he'd say
especially with andrew luck retiring
after only eight seasons
it it may have been worth it to keep
peyton around for 2012 13 14 15 and push
for a second super bowl win because
peyton manning got that second super
bowl win in denver so i i remember the
intensity of the coverage yeah what a
big deal it was nine years ago when he
was released right when he was courted
when he signed and then the double
whammy because they unloaded tebow onto
the jets after they got peyton manning
that that gave that story and even extra
uh you know a little bit of a boost yeah
you're right definitely you know of
course peyton manning we didn't know
where he was physically like what's it
going to be like
you know they have a great defense there
is their offense going to be good enough
for him to thrive and then they signed
wes welker and of course they had
demarius thomas at a young age and all
that and i mean he did special things
those first few years there's no doubt
man
i'm i'm tempted i mean because i got a
lot of good names on my list of course
there's tom brady on there jim
plunkett's a guy i think about i mean of
all the free agent signings he's the guy
that won two super bowls off after that
even though that was forever ago
but i'm gonna go with charles woodson
i'm gonna go see dub all right the old
c-dub
from michigan you know of course got
drafted by the raiders he went there had
a good first few years of his career
played in the super bowl had that like i
believe it was turf toe for a few years
there that kind of led to some
underwhelming plays on the raiders but
then went to green bay and
not only was he awesome but like a dion
sanders just gave them a different juice
on the defensive side of the ball
and could do everything nickel corner
safety whatever you want you know he
became a guy that could play really all
positions in the secondary and he was a
big part of them getting that super bowl
with aaron rodgers in 2010 and doing
that so i'll go with charles woodson as
my last one
i think it was defensive player of the
year i think you're right i think you're
right
yeah so woodson goes to green bay and
they win a super bowl
eventually
peyton manning goes to denver they win a
super bowl eventually
dion sanders has that bang bang back to
back right 99 cowboys super bowl super
bowl one each in each stop reggie white
goes to green bay they win a super bowl
eventually
drew brees goes to new orleans they went
to super bowl eventually so a super bowl
win gets you a seat at the table so
apparently tom brady yeah he has to be
tom brady right he's one and he's one
for one yeah he's the only one of all
those guys who has a chance to get to
number two and he could get to number
two as soon as this year peter king and
i were talking about this yesterday the
idea that keeping the band together is
no guarantee that you're going to be
great again it's not but but when you
have that force of nature in tom brady
who is
who is uh determined to get to number
eight it's not about number two for him
it's about number eight yeah i just i
think that
yeah i
look a lot of things can happen from
week one to week 17 into the postseason
but they're positioned they're in
they're in the conversation
more than they were last year to get the
second so i'll go with tom brady and
maybe he should have been even higher
well yeah let's take a break probably
yeah go ahead i was just saying you're
right probably probably yeah there's no
doubt i mean and you're right i mean
it's weird that we've seen a super bowl
team
that's got this many young players and
their prime and things like that that's
where it's unique compared to other i
feel like most super bowl teams you got
a lot of you know guys in the seventh
and eighth and ninth years of their
career and now they're going to look to
leave the team and get one more payday
before it all ends and that that's
what's unique about this tampa team i
also had shannon sharp on my list simeon
rice was on my list and curtis martin
was also on my list just to give those
guys love because i think they were
pretty awesome free agent signings too
simeon rice yeah i mean he was with the
cardinals you don't think of him as a
guy who was with the cardinals but he
comes to the tampa bay buccaneers 2001
and in many respects he was that last
piece of the deal it was pushed
everything over the top and helped win
the super bowl 2002.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports